Val down beehives it's Beyonce's
birthday and to celebrate we're going to
make not one but two cocktails fit for
queen bee hey guys I'm Holly Stevens its
September 4th Beyonce's bday I'm just
gonna go ahead and declare it an
unofficial national holiday and if
you're in the mood to party for bees big
day like I am I've come up with two
Beyonce inspired cocktails that'll have
you feeling so crazy in love
[Music]
first up the Beehive I knew that I
wanted to make a drink with lemonade
because let's be real was anything ever
more epic than Beyonce's visual album ya
know since beyonce is lovingly called
queen bee by her loyal fans I decided to
sweeten the lemonade with honey instead
of sugar to get started you're gonna
need six lemons 1/2 a cup of honey 11
cups of water crushed ice whiskey and
some fresh mint and lemons for garnish
so you're going to squeeze 1 cup of
juice from the lemons into the pitcher
so then you guys are gonna take a half a
cup of honey and you're gonna add it
into your pitcher whoo that is so pretty
be careful with your honey then you guys
are gonna take 11 cups of water we're
basically just making our lemonade so
you're gonna go ahead and you're gonna
pour them in the pitcher and then stir
it up it's 1 & 2 well we're getting
close to the top
protip play Beyonce's greatest hits
turned all the way up and stir on the
beat
we use on the beat and the beat so you
can go ahead and put the lemonade in the
fridge and serve it chilled as is sans
alcohol or you can turn things up with a
little liquor honey and whiskey go
together like Beyonce and jay-z or
Beyonce and windblown hair you get the
point it's legendary okay so now you're
gonna grab your preferred brand of
whiskey and you're gonna add one to two
ounces to each glass
depending on how festive you're feeling
okay so then fill the rest of your glass
with ice and a lemonade then you guys
are gonna make this so pretty and
garnish with fresh mint and a slice of
lemon all right raise your glass and
toast to Sasha Fierce but whatever you
do don't spill
[Music]
I'm not gonna lie guys I'm feeling
myself with this one good llama so I'm
spit nama soon anima our next drink is
appropriately called drunk in love
[Music]
Beyonce and jay-z rapping on a beach
about being in love sipping on
watermelon goals and that right there
that was my inspiration for cocktail
number two to get started you guys are
gonna need nine cups of chilled
watermelon one cup of coconut water four
tablespoons fresh lime juice 1 cup of
vodka crushed ice and mint lime and
watermelon for your garnish throw your
watermelon coconut water and fresh lime
juice in a blender and blend until it's
smooth pour the mixture into a large
pitcher add your vodka and stir fill
your glasses with crushed ice and pour
that watermelon goodness all over it to
finish this up we're gonna garnish it
with a teeny tiny little watermelon
slice how cute is that cuz you know
she's been sipping watermelon then take
a few little lime wedges and you're
gonna throw those in and then finish up
with a little bit of mint and voila
if pretty hurts this one is killing me
flawless
[Music]
now it wouldn't be a birthday without
some sweets and to keep it on theme
serve your friends some I don't think
you're ready for this jelly cookies
cupcakes by the pound alone it's the
brown paper and who run the world
swirls brownies happy birthday Beyonce
we love you so much and if you guys
liked this video come on back we're
going to have more how to throw videos
coming your way soon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]